Bob: Oh fine, nobody wants to be on Bob's team, whatever.
Mark: I'll be on your team, Bob.
Mark: Oh jeez, uh- whoops.
Jack: I also like how I have errors and purples everywhere.
Mark: Oh my god.
Jack: Despite taking 20 hours to download the map.
Wade: *laughs*
Mark: This map sucks.
Jack: *laughs*
Bob: It works for me perfectly.
Mark: Oh Jesus.
Jack: Nooo!
Bob: This map is fine!
Mark: *laughs* Oh Jesus!
Wade: Oh my god.
Jack: Don't say that.
Wade: I can't see anything
Mark: Keep going, keep going guys!
Mark: Just keep going with this, it's good!
Mark: I'm not even playing right now, I'm spectating.
Jack: OH! What the-?
Wade: It looks fine for me!
Mark: Oh my god, oh my god, the CABINETS are errors!
Mark: The gas station is an error!
Bob: Hey, am I an error? Don't shoot me.
Bob: Don't shoot me, I'm right next to you, Jack.
Jack: No, you're a pot.
Bob: Oh, cool.
Wade: What are (unintelligible)?
Bob: WADE'S GONNA KILL ME!
*grenade*
Bob: Goddammit! Oh, it was you (Jack)!
Jack: *laughs*
Wade: Wow!
Wade: I like how I get accused!
Bob: Wade...
Jack: The comedic timing was too good!
Mark: Oh my god, this is gonna be so hard to watch! *laughs*
Jack: Do you have, like the entire inside of the building is all pink?
Mark: Yeah. Oh yeah.
Bob: No, no. Mine's fine.
Bob: Mine's actually is totally fine though.
Bob: I have literally no errors right now.
Mark: Bob,
Jack: Really? I'm seeing purple.
Mark: Come downstairs, I love this TV program.
Mark: Everything's purple. Everything.
Jack: Yeah.
Mark: Should we try to get a new game then?
Bob: Yeah, I suppose.
Wade: Do we? Yeah, I can do that.
Jack: I'm in!
Bob: Erm, that's not how it works.
Mark: Wait! We're starting?! WHAT?
Jack: Can we pick teams?
Wade: Is everybody in?
Mark: Wait WHAT THE FUCK?!
Mark: I GAVE UP BECAUSE YOU GUYS TOLD ME TO STOP!
Wade: Jack restarted the thing.
Mark: Ohhh. Ok, oh phew.
Wade: He turned it to "Maps Only."
Mark: Well, I'll do that then. Alright.
Wade: OH MY GOD! I THOUGHT THAT'S WHAT WE ALL AGREED TO DO!
Jack: I didn't stop the fucking GAME!
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: WE DIDN'T AGREE TO DO ANYTHING!
Wade: WHY ARE THERE SO MANY FUCKING HUNTERS?!
Mark: I don't know. Guys, I'm in.
Wade: Great, everybody's in.
Bob: Alright, I'mma pick Hunter.
Mark: Alright.
Bob: "Hunters WIN!"
Jack: *laughs*
Mark: Alright, I'm in.
Wade: Did we just end up with the same teams as last time?
Mark: I don't know.
Bob: Yes.
Jack: This map is awful.
Mark: I'm with Bob.
Bob: Oh my god.
Wade: What do you mean?! This is a 5-Star Map!
Mark: Yeah, but it was brand new, so maybe only one person rated it.
Bob: It's so white! Oh no! There's an invisible walls!
Bob: Oh, it's not invisible if you do that.
Bob: Oh Christ, hang on.
Jack: Invisible if you just believe.
Bob: I need like 35 more seconds. Hang on!
Mark: Aye yai yai! Woah.
Jack: Well you only got 13!
Bob: SHIT!
Mark: THAT'S not what I intended.
Jack: And now it's less than that!
Mark: Woah.
Bob: I'm fine, this is fine! Everything's fine!
Jack [squeakily]: Everything is appropriate!
Mark: I can't see shit!
Mark: The map is too small.
Jack: Here we go!
Wade: Welcome to Prop Hunt, everybody.
Mark: Wait. Oh fuck.
Bob: Fuckin'... Fuck!
Bob: Cock-Fucking Fuck!
Wade: I feel like I've played Gmod Guess Who on this map.
Jack: I feel like I should see you guys already by your expletives.
Wade: Oh hi.
Mark: Fuck.
*explosion*
Mark: Fuck!
Bob: No NO GOD JESUS MAN!
Wade: AHK!
Mark: Oh, I thought that was me.
Jack: Why'd you kill yourself?
Bob: See? Wade doesn't ever like to have any fun whatsoever!
Mark: That sounds like Wade.
Bob: If Wade played Tetris, he would just stack the blocks neatly,
Bob: and finish the level, like a FUCKING DICK!
Wade: *laughs*
Jack: Bob, you're dead, you don't get to talk anymore.
Bob: Oh.
Jack: *laughs*
Wade: Wait. Hey Jack, am I hanging out the window for you?
Jack: No, you're just on the ground in the corner.
Mark: Bob! How am I?
Bob: Oh my god, you're a wizard!
Mark: Yeah, did I do it?
Jack: How the FUCK am I gonna find you?
Jack: Every house-
Bob: Could you scoot toward the middle of the-
Bob: OH! Don't scoot! Oh! Stop moving!
Jack: Oh wait. Ok.
Mark: Ok, stopped.
Bob: You're a wizard! You're a straight-up wizard.
Mark: Yeah? Yeah! Yeah! Okay, alright, good!
Bob: Ok, well... Yeah! You're good!
Wade: Is there only two houses that are actually searchable?
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: Aside from the fact that the rest of the room looks a little bit like an apocalypse,
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: it's pretty good.
Jack: Ok, so he's back in the other house then.
Bob: Just ignore that.
Mark: Nonono! God damn it Bob! You sold me!
Mark: You got rid of me. *laughs*
Jack: Yeah, "You ratted me out, jeez."
Bob: Oh no. Sorry. They'll never find you.
Bob: They're not even close.
Mark: I see someone out the window in the WRONG HOUSE!
Mark: HA HA HA!
Bob: You're in the WRONG house!
Mark: Yeah, WRONG HOUSE, LOSER!
Mark: Why don't you go across the street, NERD?
Jack: Why don't YOU reveal yourself?
Bob: Better recheck your house number.
Bob: I think you got the wrong number, brah.
Mark: Wait. Yeah.
Wade: I think you're in the right place, Jack.
Jack: Nothing looks-
Mark: Maybe you need to call 911 to get yourself out of this sticky situation!
Jack: NOTHING LOOKS WRONG HERE!
Bob: Yeah, uhh.
Wade: Oh, "Sticky" is a clue, he's goo!
Bob: Like I said before,
Jack: He's SEMEN! He's semen on the roof.
Mark: I'm an old sock under the bed!
Wade: He's semen on the roof!
Bob: *giggles*
Wade: "Semen on the Roof," the sequel to "Fiddler on the Roof."
Jack: I'm knocking shit down just by standing still!
Bob: Semen on the roof! *laughs*
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: That's actually the, uh, the concurrent sequel of "The Semen of the Fiddler on the Roof."
Bob: And it's written from the perspective of his unborn child.
Wade: "Semen of the Fiddler on the Roof."
Jack: The Martin Scorsese epic!
Mark: It's also known as "Diddler on the Roof."
Bob: "The Semen in the Fiddler on the Roof." *laughs*
Jack: "Fiddler on the Roof."
Bob: "The Semen in the Fiddler on the Roof."
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: Or, "Semen on the Roof."
Jack: Where the fuck is he? Gimme a hint!
Wade: Is Mark in the room with the lamps on the floor and the-?
Bob: Also see the campy revamp of it,
Bob: "Semen around," not as serious,
Bob: Some found it offensive, but honestly, some good songs.
Jack: Are you done?
Mark: And- and the sister movie, "The Semenist,"
Wade: Oh boy.
Mark: was also a classic, that was regarded by-.
*BOOM*
Mark: Woah!
Bob: Is that the one where-
Wade: *laughs*
Mark: Oh jeez! *laughs*
Bob: *laughs* Well,
Jack: Sick of listening to your crap!
Bob: All we have to do is tell horrible jokes until they decide to kill themselves!
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: And THAT'S how you win!
Mark: That DOES make it pretty easy huh?
Jack: It's almost IMPOSSIBLE to get into this house and not knock shit down!
Mark: Okay.
Bob: *still laughing*
Mark: You guys were in the complete wrong house!
Mark: Like, you were just...
Bob: You were in, you were in the other house, yeah!
Wade: I was dead.
Mark: Oh, yeah, Jack, you were just in the wrong house.
Bob: "The Semenist," was that "Exorcist"? Was that-?
Mark: No, I was going for "The Pianist." "The Pianist," "The Semenist." It didn't come across.
Bob: Ohhh.
Bob: I sort of meant the heart-wrenching, uh, the heart-wrenching movie that featured a great performance.
Bob: Uh, by that actor I don't know, "Semen's List."
Mark: Yeah, yeah. *laughs*
Jack: Semen Neeson?
Bob: Semen- Semen Neeson in "Semen's List: List Even Harder."
Bob: No that would be "Semen's List 3."
Jack [Duke Nukem voice]: Cum harder.
Bob: Cum- *giggle* "The Semen-"
Jack: Was that too on-the-nose?
Bob: That's a little much, okay?
*glass smash*
Bob: That's in time!
Mark: Woah, what the fuck just happened?
Bob: I don't know if you figured it out yet, that's my entire life.
Wade: Who's shooting and breaking stuff?
Mark: Wait a minute... What the fuck did that?
*glass smash*
Mark: Woah! Who's here?
Wade: Wait, what?
Jack: What's happening?
Wade: Who's smashing?
Jack: Yeah, good question.
Bob: Are you in the same house as me, Mark?
Bob: Or are you in the other one?
Mark: No, I'm in the other house.
Mark: I'm in a HAUNTED house! The dishes keep breaking at random!
Wade: *laughs*
Jack: Oh yeah, when you walk past shit and it just, like, falls over and breaks.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: So you saw that, did ya?
*shattering*
Wade: What in the world?!
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: Mark, is that you, just breaking everything?
Mark: Yeah.
Jack: Wait, Bob, go into that little shed.
Jack: See if you can find the thing.
Bob: Yeah yeah!
Wade: Stop breaking my brothers and sisters!
Jack: Is that how you get in?
Mark: Oh, wait.
Bob: Yep.
Mark: What are you talking about, Wade? Was I close?
Mark: Was I on-the-nose?
Wade: Maybe. Maybe you were close.
Mark: Maybe I was close. Maybe YOU are-
Wade: Maybe I'm a liar.
Mark: Maybe you're a DEAD, man.
Mark: Ok.
Wade: Ahh! It hurt!
Bob: I really just wanna find the basement.
Wade: Please keep hitting that!
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: Alright, Wade, I've got your number.
Jack: What are you doing there Bob?
*glass breaks*
Mark: I've got your number Wade.
Mark: Woah!
Jack: What the FUCK is HAPPENING?
Wade: Oh I see you! There you are!
Bob: I'm not doing anything. What are YOU doing?
Wade: Oh, now I don't see you. Hey! There ya are- nope.
Wade: Heyyyyy!
Jack: I'm just hearing explosions everywhere.
Bob: Nah, it's fine.
Mark: It's really bright on this map too like, really bright.
Wade: Hey friend!
Jack: You find the basement?
Wade: Where ya goin'?
Bob: No.
Mark: Hang on, hang on guys
*BOOM*
Bob: Found the laundry room.
Wade: I don't see you anymore.
Mark: Alright, wait, okay. I think Wade's in this house- oh.
Mark: Hello.
*glass breaks*
Mark: Woah!
Mark: Jeezums.
Jack: Yeah, you just walk by shit and it smashes.
Mark: Huh.
Mark: Alright Bob, we gotta start making calls here.
Wade: Oh, hi. *BANG*
*all laugh*
Mark: Wo-o-o-o-oah
Jack: Made the right call!
*all laugh*
Bob: Yeah, all you gotta do is- Wait, Mark.
Bob: Look at this flag.
Bob: Over here at this house for a second.
Mark: Oh shit.
Mark: Hang on, I gotta be patriotic for a second here.
Wade: Oh Jack, you are golden.
Bob: Oh wait, it's okay. Wait, no Mark.
Bob: Come look at it from this angle please.
Mark: Yeah?
*both laugh*
Jack: Is it frozen?
Bob: Yeah, it's like, it's like it's waving in the air, but it's stuck.
Bob: It looks super fucked up from the side.
Mark: It fills me with PRIDE! That's good.
Wade: Jack, that is absurd.
*BANG*
Jack: I know right. Hehe, I feel a little bad. *laughs*
Mark: Is it absurd? Wait, hang on. Is it absurd though? Is it? Absurd?
Jack: It's a little absurd.
Wade: It's almost as ridiculous as someone being a giant red cooler running around.
*both laugh*
Wade: Toying with Mark.
Mark: "Toying" with me, huh?
Bob: Are they toying with Mark or me?
Wade: No, I was toying with Mark, and then you came outside and shot me.
Mark: Um, he MIGHT be a pair of glasses, maybe?
Jack: *error buzzer*
Mark: That means I'm right!
Jack: No.
Bob: No, I see him, he's out here.
Bob: Aw, I fuckin' shot your brother earlier.
Jack: *laughs* Don't shoot my fuckin' bro!
Mark: What is he? What was he coming in?
Bob: He's a little coaster on the ground.
Mark: Oh wait, I saw him run by.
Jack: I'm an ASHTRAY!
Wade: *laughs* Get it right!
Mark: Saw him running by.
Bob: I shot the thing that you became!
*BOOM*
Mark: He's a dirty coaster. He's a DIRTY COASTER!
Wade: OH MY GOD!
Mark: I helped, Bob, I helped!
Bob: You're just a nasty little shit-disk.
Jack: Well I was originally an accordion in that room you went into.
Mark: Ahh.
Bob: Aw really?
Jack: Yeah.
Bob: Shit. Um, I can't see where the fence is and is not.
Mark: Alright, Bob. Where you goin'?
Bob: So apparently I'm not going over there.
Mark: Yeah.
Jack: That's o-fence-ive, never mind.
Bob: Alright.
Jack: Listen closely, Wade! They'll give away what they are.
Wade: Ok.
Bob: I'm going bold, I'm going bold, Mark.
Mark: Ok.
Jack: He's a FONT!
Bob: *laughs* Got me.
Wade: Yeah, that's a good call.
Jack: He's an "ERROR" sign!
Wade: He's Comic Sans.
Bob: I am definitely an error sign. Of all the things.
Mark: Don't listen to the-
Mark: Don't listen to the EXTREME noise!
Bob: *laughs*
Wade: That's very obviously coming from this house.
Mark: Don't listen to that!
Jack: *laughs*
Bob: *laugh continues*
Mark: That is NONE of your concern!
Bob: This is fine. Don't come in.
Bob: I don't need your help.
Jack: This is fine.
Mark: Don't come in my room, mom. Please leave.
Bob: Please, go away.
Jack: Oh, I found the basement!
Wade: Now, do you really want to go find them, or do you just want to hang out in this cool basement?
Jack: Yeah, right!
Bob: It's like a 300 degree, black-and-white picture of a valley.
Mark: Nice.
Jack: Dude, there's a bar in here! We should just get drinks!
Wade: Yeah, I agree.
Bob: I wonder if that's copyrighted.
Wade: Thank you.
Bob: I'm gonna keep looking at it.
Wade: Next!
Bob: Mark, are you still alive?
Mark: Yeah, I'm still alive.
Mark: I'm in a good hidey hole, I think.
Wade: Thank you for smashing that one over my head, it made it taste better!
Jack: No problem!
Wade: *drinking noise* Thank you!
Jack: Do you want- Do you want Jacopic Beer?
Wade: I want THAT- Oh, well you grabbed them both.
Wade: Yeah, that's fine. I don't care.
Jack: I don't know what that is. We have Pep.
Wade: Wait, do you have Top-Shelf over there?
Jack: We have Crush.
Jack: We have Lithi-Cola something.
Wade: Oh yeah.
Jack: Non-copyrighted sodas.
Bob: Yeah.
Wade [drunk]: I'm kinda hammered now, but just-
Bob: Right here.
Wade [drunk]: You closed the door in it, behind me.
Bob: I was pretty interested to see how that spot was gonna work out, but I guess no one's gonna come play with me.
Mark: No, it's fine, don't worry about it dude.
Mark: Someone will like you eventually.
Bob: Why don't you just come in?
Jack: Nothing looks off in here.
Bob: Why don't you just come on in and have a seat?
Mark: *huffy grunts*
Bob: *laughs heartily*
Mark: *grunts* *laughs* *coughs*
Bob: Why don't you just come sit down?
Bob: Why don't you come have a seat?
Mark: Yeah,
Mark: Why don't you have a seat? (x3)
Wade: What does that mean?
Bob: Are you also a sitting thing, Mark?
Mark: *bupping* Nope.
Bob: *giggles*
Jack: Oh, you're reacting to HIM, I thought you were reacting to ME.
Mark: Uh, I don't know WHO that was, but... nothing!
Bob: Someone's out in the street, and someone's in the wrong house.
Wade: Hmm... I take it that means I'm in the wrong house.
Bob: Well since only one of you is IN a house,
*BANG*
Jack: FUCK!
Mark: WOAH! Woahoho!
Jack: Did I get close?
Mark: No, no, I had slipped. I slipped, so, like I-
Mark: I JUST managed to get behind you and then around the back of the shed.
Jack: SHIT!
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: Wade!
Mark: I mean NO! WADE! Wade, don't think about this!
Jack: You're in the right direction!
Mark: HeyYYy! Hey hey hey.
Bob: Mark, come towards me!
Mark: Ok, alright. Where are you? I don't know.
Bob: I will protect you.
Bob: Uh, sure, you know where I am.
Mark: Okay, alright, I'm coming to you! I'm gone!
Jack: I don't know what he is.
Bob: What's the taunt button?
Wade: Jack, what is he?
Jack: I don't know! I didn't see anything move!
Mark: *giggles*
Wade: What did you shoot?!
Bob: Mark, I'm flashing my light, come to me!
Jack: Ohh.
Mark: You don't have a- Oh! I DO see your light!
Mark: Holy shit, I see your light! Holy fuck!
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: I'm coming Bob! OH GOD! There's no line! AHHH!
Bob: Come to me Mark! *laughs*
Mark: Oh! AHH!
Bob: *laughs harder*
Jack: They're outside Wade! The other side of the house!
Bob: Mark! DON'T come to me!
Mark: I'm coming to you!
Wade: I can't leave-
Wade: OH GOD! I'm-
Jack: No! WHY?! I just gave them away!
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: Yay!
Wade: I accidentally Right Clicked!
Mark: *laughs harder*
Bob: Hello friend!
Mark: Oh, you would not believe the ADVENTURE I had, Bob!
Bob: *laughs*
Jack: Fuck's sake, Wade, we had that!
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: *laughs*
Wade: I know.
Mark: You're just a BENCH! Jesus.
Jack: He was a bench at the back, near a tree.
Bob: I know, I was just a bench sitting out in the open!
Bob: Hey, the other benches were all near trees, okay? So I was just playing my character. Don't be judgey about this.
Mark: Oh man. Yeah.
Mark: It was fucking ridiculous because I had just managed to slip out the door of Jack,
Mark: and then like Wade just BEELINES towards me, I don't know how I got away!
Jack: Ah fuck!
Wade: I don't know how you got away either!
Bob: Hey! I see someone is in a shed!
Jack: Ah shit stains.
Mark: Uh oh!
Jack: Shit stain! Come on man! How did this-?
Mark: Wait, ok, I got you covered.
Wade: Oh come on Jack! No!
Jack: WHY?! *laughs*
Mark: Is that- Is that what I think it is?
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: Is that what I think it is?
Mark: Alright, we'll give you another shot.
Jack: You guys see nothin'!
Mark: Wait, nonono, let's play, we'll close the door.
Bob: Here, yeah, what if I open- OH GOD! Hang on!
Mark: Woa- OH NO!
Bob: I'm stuck.
Jack: *laughs*
Mark: There, ok, we're good.
Bob: There we go, here we go, wait.
Jack: I can't move!
Bob: Can we open this other door and help you?
Mark: Uhh, wait, I'm trying to push you in. Ohh boy.
Jack: I can't even close THIS door!
Bob: Oh, we'll push it, we'll push you in!
Jack: Ok, I can't become anything else.
Jack: Let me fuckin' move!
Mark: What if we give you an object?
Mark: What if we give you something?
Bob: We're working on it! We're wedging you in there.
Bob: It's fine. This is fine.
Jack: I'm pressin' stuff!
Mark: There you go!
Bob: There you go, you popped in!
Mark: Ok, alright. We're gonna look away!
Mark: We're gonna close the door.
Jack: Okay. Wait wait.
Jack: Ok, I'mma hide really good in here! You guys won't even know.
Mark: Alright. Alright cool.
Wade: *laughs*
Mark: Alright, you have a good one! *smooch* Have a good day at school.
Jack: Ok, wait, you can look again! You can look again!
Jack: You can look again. I changed. I changed.
Mark: Oh, I'm gonna go look, let's see what happened.
Mark: Alright, 3, 2, 1.  Wooop!
Jack: I got stuck again.
*all laugh*
Jack: I don't know how this happened!
Mark: It's just the magic closet! *laughs*
Bob: *laughs*
*shovel clangs*
Bob: You know what? I don't think he needs any help. I think we should just leave him be.
Mark: Yeah. Woah!
Bob: And, you know, we'll come back and check on you in a bit, okay buddy?
Mark: Yeah, we'll come back. You just cook for a bit.
Jack: Okay.
Mark: You cook. Yep.
Jack: Guys...
Jack: I can pick up shit, but it won't let me BECOME it! WHY?!
Mark: I just hear the clanging.
Bob: *laughs*
Bob: Yeah, it's just like, wham, crash, bash, oh no.
Jack: WHY?! This is my fucking HELL!
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: Oh, fuck's sake.
Bob: Wait, so, where is the basement? I'm interested in that.
Jack: When you go in the house, it's on the hall, it's one of the doors in the hall.
Jack: It's just like camouflaged against the wall, it's a brown door.
Mark: Ahh.
Jack [to Wade]: Bye, bye, buddy.
Bob: Every step I take is like, I'm a god damn giant, destroying the universe.
Mark: Hey Bob, I saw something.
Wade: No you didn't.
Mark: Yeah I did. Bob, you wanna come out and see the Magical Changing Shed again?
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: No! Don't look at my SHAME!
Bob: *laughs*
Jack: I'm changing in here!
Jack: Or at least TRYING to!
Mark: Bob, why don't you check behind that tree in the corner?
Wade: No, not this tree!
Bob: Oh, oh hey.
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: There's nothing behind this tree.
Jack: No! Look at me! Look how silly I am!
Mark: Let's play a little game.
Jack: Oh I goofed! Guys, look, I can't move, I goofed!
Bob: What if I slowly walked this way, around the tree?
Wade: Not this tree. No.
Bob: What if I slowly look, this way and-
Bob: Oh no, there's nothing here!
Wade: Not behind this shed.
*BANG*
*BANG* *BANG*
Wade: Ah! Why are you shooting at me?!
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: I'm not shooting at you.
*BANG*
Wade: No, I'm just a tree.
Jack: I'm shooting AROUND you!
*BANG*
Wade: Hey, have you ever heard of Connectico Motor Oil?
*ratatatatata*
Wade: It's the best!
Jack: Have you ever heard of-
Mark: He's unkillable! He's unkillable!
Wade: Get your oil today! Connectico Oil! Here to stay!
Mark: He's unkillable!
Wade: Connectico!
Mark: Oh, there you go.
Jack: That was just embarassing.
Jack: And I'M the one stuck in the ground!
Mark: Yeah, that was bad for me. Alright, so what we'll do- Oh, fuck.
Bob: I'm gonna ride you to victory, Jack! Let's do this!
Mark: Alright.
Jack: Okay, okay, I'm not moving.
Bob: Is this working?
Jack: No, I can't pick up anything. I can't move
Bob: Here, I'll push you. *gasp* I'm inside you!
Bob: Huhh! Alright, there we go.
Jack: Guh!
Bob: Shouldn't YOU be the one making that sound if I'm inside you?
Mark: Alright, I think this is gonna be a mercy, okay?
Jack: Just fucking kill me.
*KERPOW* *Ch-ch*
Jack: Thank you.
Bob: Oh my god!
Mark: Woah!
Jack: Oh wow!
Bob: Oh it lit on fire, oh fuck! Oh gosh!
Mark: Woahohoh!
Bob: Everything's burning down!
Wade: Can I help?
Mark: The shed is ANGRY!
Jack: I was the fire all along!
Jack: Piece of shit, fucking game.
Jack: Messin' with my life.
Jack: My fun.
Mark: My life, my fun, my world, my game!
Wade: I tried to help you, Jack.
Jack: I only care about M.E., My Enjoyment!
Wade: Oh.
Mark: It's called "Sean's Mod" for a reason, guys!
Jack: Yeah!
Wade: Yeah!
Mark: Yeah...
Jack: Ok.
Bob: Oh fuck's sake!
Jack: I hear a cliggity clang. A pliggity plang. Outside the housie-doo.
Bob: Nah, it's fine. Everything's fine, nothing happened.
Bob: Everything's fine, don't worry about it!
Jack: Is it?
Bob: Yeah, it's fine.
Jack: *laughs* "Everything's fine," *clang* *clong* *cug*.
Wade: So, Mark, you wanna talk about this?
Mark: NAAAOOOOO!!
Wade: Oh my god, you scared me!
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: Oh my- That scared the shit outta me!
Jack: Holy fuck!
Wade: I jumped so high!
Mark: WaAAhoohoohoo!
Wade: When you screamed, I just jumped!
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: Sorry, I panicked! I panicked!
Wade: It was one of those moments when I threw my mouse.
Jack: It made me jump in real life.
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: Oh my god.
Mark: Oh Jesus.
Wade: Mark I'm stuck.
Jack: Bob, are you here?
Mark: Good, you should stay that way.
Bob: Are you the one in the bar, Jack?
Jack: Yeah.
Bob: Nah, I'm not in there.
Jack: Heh, "Are you the one in the bar with me?" "Yeah, I'm not in there."
Mark: NO-HO-HO-HO!!!!! NOOOOOOO!!!!
Wade: *laughs*
Wade: So um, you didn't scare me this time, buddy.
Jack: The fuck is happening?
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: Alright, okay, alright, okay.
Jack: Someone's giving birth!
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: I'm not gonna panic, I'm gonna take this like a man.
Mark: I'm gonna just stick my ass up against this radiator and-
Jack: It's a bit too late to-
Bob: Oh no!
Jack: Oh hey!
Mark: Fuckin- geh- Eh! Eh! Eh! Eh! Eh!
Mark: HA! Hoho!
Jack: I did it! I just randomly shot that chair.
Wade: I just saw that garbage can rolling behind the house!
Bob: How the fuck? It looked fine!
Mark: I know! *laughs* Jesus.
Jack: No it didn't, you were sideways.
Bob: It was fine.
Jack: You were side-ways.
Wade: Funny story Mark, last round I did the same thing, that's how I knew it was you!
Mark: Yeah? Aw, shit.
Mark: *laughs* Oh jeez.
Wade: *laughs*
Bob: *laughs*
Jack: Okay. Be smart.
Jack: That's not smart!
Bob: B-6. Hit! (Battleship)
Jack: *chuckles*
Mark: Nice.
Wade: Uh oh, uh oh, uh oh.
Jack: Sick joke, dude!
Mark: Was that from Battleship the game or Battleship the movie?
Bob: Battleship the movie, bro!
Mark: NICE!
Jack: Yeah, fuckin' Liam Neeson up in this.
Mark: Nice. Fuckin', Rihanna up in this.
Bob: Fuckin' McSteamy from Grey's Anatomy, bro!
Wade: Well.
Wade: I'm stuck, but I think it's okay.
Bob: I see a chair running around. What's going on over here?
*Jack licks the top row of his teeth*
Jack [ leans into the mic and says,quietly]: Nothing.
Mark [quietly]: Nothing.
Wade: I'm stuck, but it's fine! It's fine Jack.
Bob: Oh.
Wade: There's nothing to worry about.
Bob: I- This chair looks a little suspicious, but-
Jack [leans in]: Whatcha doin', buddy? That's fine!
Bob: In the context of a-
Jack [overblowing mic]: THAT'S FINE, BUDDY! IT'S FINE, DON'T EVEN WORRY ABOUT IT, THAT'S FINE! DON'T EVEN-
[Wade is deadeded by Jack's critical ear rape attack!]
Mark: *laughs* Oh my god!
Bob: *laughs* Oh my god.
Jack [overblowing mic]: DON'T EVEN FUCKING WORRY ABOUT IT! DON'T FUCKING WORRY.
Mark: Jesus Christ!
Jack [overblowing mic]: IT'S FUC- IT'S FUCKING FINE.
Bob [yelling]: HEY, I CAN HEAR MYSELF IF I YELL!
Bob: Oh, it went away.
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: *laughs*
Wade: *gone*
Bob: Oh oh AH! OH!
Jack: It's fine. (x7)
Bob: *laughs heartily*
Mark: JESUS! I'm watching through the window! This is NOT FINE!
Jack: AW FUCK! AH SHIT!
Mark: Bob, what's happening in there? Bob? You might want to- Uh oh, Bob!
Jack: No, it's fine, it's fine. Now it's fine.
Bob: *laughs* It's fine.
Bob: It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Jack: Now it's fine. NOW it's fine. AH GOD! I CAN'T SEE IT MOVE!
Jack: Can't fuckin' see shit! WHERE IS THE EXIT?!
Bob: *laughs*
Jack: WHERE'S THE OFF RAMP?!
Wade: *laughs*
Bob [laughing]: It's not in any of the places you've gone so far!
Jack: Eh! Eh! Eh! Eh!!! EH!! EH! EHH!!
Bob: Aw shit!
*BOOM*
Mark: *laughs heartily*
Bob: Oh fucking god! *laughs heartily*
Jack: NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!
Wade: So...
Wade: Um...
Jack: Ohhh!
Bob: *still laughing heartily*
Mark: *rolling laugh*
Jack: Fucking! THIS SUCKS!
Jack: I was fine.
Mark: I opened that door, hoping you would come out. *laughs*
Bob: *laughs*
Jack: Fucking. Thanks for playing, Bob, thanks, thanks.
Bob: Oh, fucking shit, god damn. That makes my sides hurt.
Mark: Oh man.
Bob: Yeah, I was nice, right? I was cool? It's cool?
Jack: Yeah. It's that other one.
Mark: Yeah, it's me! *laughs*
Jack: Mark FischPoop.
Bob: WADE!
Wade: Woah, woah! I knew you were gonna accuse me, Bob!
Bob: Yeah, it's almost like that's an accurate thing to accuse you of.
Jack: Wade, I think you're pretty solid, Wade.
Wade: Yeah, but I can't actually move, so...
Jack: I mean, they're in the same house, but, you're pretty solid.
Wade: I'm sure I'm fine. They'll never- They wouldn't dare look here.
Jack: They'll probably leave.
Wade: Oh hey, they looked here.
Jack: Ohhh...
Jack [harsh whisper]: I think us talking out loud may have ruined that!
Wade: They can't hear us.
Wade: With the power of imagination-
Jack: Someone's outside like a fuckin-
Jack: Someone's outside like a macaroon though.
Wade: Yeah, I hear them stomping in the snow.
Mark: I'm watching.
Jack: Apparently it's probably that- It's probably that 'Plier!
Wade: Yeah.
Bob: I don't understand.
Bob: I think Wade's a tiny thing underneath a thing, but I'm not sure.
Jack: He's not. He's not.
Wade: No, I'm not.
Mark: So he's a-
Jack: He's actually pretty easy to find if you're not stupid.
Mark: Yeah.
Wade: Yeah.
Bob: Well then, I must not have looked in the right room yet, 'cause I know I'm stupid.
Wade: Yeah, that's quite accurate.
Mark: Hmmm... Hmmm...
Jack: Yeah, probably.
*muffled boom*
Wade: I'm sure I'm- GAH HA!
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: *laughs*
Bob: You're right! Once I walked into the right room, it was IMMEDIATELY clear!
Jack: I told you.
Wade: Oh hey, there's Mark in the window.
Mark: Hiiii, I'm here too, guys.
Bob: *laughs*
Wade: Jack, we had great scores! I feel good about it.
Jack: Ooo!
*"Crazy La Paint" by MiniMusicMan plays*
*music descends*
*music descends out*